and the CMA Award for Entertainer of the
Year goes to Taylor Swift Taylor Swift
Taylor Swift Taylor Swift what if your
fairytale dream came true but you were
still miserable the fame the boyfriend
the songs about the boyfriend well it
starts out fun there's always got to be
like a little bit of glimmer of good for
a relationship to go bad for you to miss
it
this Christmas experience love like you
never have before
the eyes of a billionaire starring
Johnny Depp as John Mayer Sylar
as Joe Jonas Jared Leto as Jake
Gyllenhaal Kris Humphries as Taylor
Lautner Rachel Bilson as Selena Gomez
Emily Osment as rival Carrie Underwood
and in a comeback performance no one saw
coming
Keira as Taylor Swift and the flower to
heart right about this like oh did you
yes